Tiffany why are you in Los Angeles today
I just gave a keynote to this Cisco
conference yesterday and then I'm giving
another one to a different group at the
conference today and I'm talking about
my cloud filmmaking and I show clips
from connected and talk about where I
think all this connectedness came from
and where I think it's going and the
potential technologically with cinema
and creativity you mentioned you were
one of the few artists in the room I'm
always yeah a lot of technology company
a lot of businesses like well had me
come in on the I am the artist but I'm
also a technologist so I started off my
talk histor day just a little I said
William Gibson who I just heard speech
said if you want to know where
technology is headed just look at what
the artists and the criminals are doing
and I said I'm the artist side of that
equation so because we're doing a lot of
experiments that you could apply to
anything that are really working and I
also tell them about things that didn't
work and and how are you received is are
the arms crossed window get up there or
because I have my films I have a lot of
I show a lot of my short films which are
very funny and but they're provocative
and you know I always try to use humor
as a way to open up bigger issues that
might be uncomfortable
so I'm tempering the whole film filled
with the whole talk with films and ideas
and discussion but no I I speak a lot
I've been doing it for 20 years and I I
give about you know one to two keynotes
a month yeah when you see what the
criminals are doing or you were for
instance something like anonymous or
what water-saving inmates calm or what
like well no I definitely think like I'm
just quoting Gibson so I what I loved
about what he said is I you know I've
always you know antennas are artists or
like the antennas of society and they're
always experimenting and doing things or
commenting on things that maybe the rest
of the society it's not mainstream yet
they're like on the edges of society or
they're experimenting with things at the
edges
and then once it gets brought into the
center that's when it becomes mainstream
so I mean I've always been kind of
exploring the edge and one of my
favorite quotes by my dad is when if
you're not living on the edge you're
taking up too much space that's
definitely a philosophy in my work so
I'm to always try to experiment with how
things are done and rethinking how films
are made and how they can be distributed
and providing new tools for people to
experience the content in films and I
really I mean more than a filmmaker I
think of myself as a conversation maker
and I'm trying to provide all these
different ways to experience and
interact with ideas and to delve deeper
into ideas so yeah so I mean I think
criminal's is just kind of edgy because
know there's a lot of hackers and people
doing things that are revealing holes in
the system things that be fixed I just
read this very haunting article by this
wired editor who got completely hacked
and the attacker his whole identity told
him what he did and why he did it
because he wanted the reporter to tell
these companies to fix the holes in
their system so it was a really
interesting article but I and I'm not
proponent you know I'm not when I used
that quote at the beginning it was more
to talk about here's a perspective of an
artist working at the fringes of what
you can do with technology and
you